elamos proclaims himself as
emperor of mars entrepreneur the
co-founder of private space exploration
company spacex elamos noted that the key
to preventing the extinction of animals
and planets on earth lies
on mars in a tweet this weekend elon
musk remarked that if we manage to make
life interplanetary it will not matter
if it becomes extinct on earth page 3
because it will live on the red planet a
few days ago
musk took advantage of the excitement
caused by the company's
reusable robots to proclaim himself in
his tweets biography twitter biography
as
emperor of mars it should be remembered
that musk constantly changes his
description on the social network and
has called himself currency
advisor as in game of thrones because of
his internet
interest in digital currencies such as
dutch dogecoin
so adam what are you thinking about uh
elon musk being the emperor of mars
uh kai real quick give ricky your notes
you he's got the notes from yeah
all right no nobody will change change
with him
um number one shout out to earth
shout out to earth it's probably my
favorite planet that i've ever been on
um shout out to earth today is earth day
so
i know that elon musk is obsessed with
mars and kudos to him for that
and i know that he's the proclaimed
emperor of mars and respect i know that
he's banging martians
and he's turned his girlfriend into an
alien i get it
but just shout out to you say that what
do you mean by that have you not seen
what she looks like i sincerely don't
know what you're doing
okay you don't know what alien yes i
don't know what to do
okay pull up um our friend uh
uh what's her name again grimes pull up
grimes
this is um elon musk i think he's a v
let me get let me give you the
to use a dogecoin reference that that's
his girl that's his girl
um oh yeah you're into that
ricardo myself down down in uh michigan
this is how you get down or no
okay i didn't think so so let's give the
uh different sides of dogecat he's a
visionary
he's a dreamer he's a big thinker he's
an absolute billionaire
respect he's toying with people though
i'm the emperor of mars but i think he
also
yeah he might be toying with people but
i also think
he does have some sort of a god complex
we talked about that last night i think
he's getting a little
too otherworldly for his own good i
think
he's doing a lot of good things i'm an
elon musk fan but i
do think he's kind of getting you know
what but you know what though but you
know what here
i don't think anybody he nobody should
be a software team i don't think he's
even made that statement
but i did say he's the emperor of mars
no emperor being an emperor and consider
yourself a god or two different things
i said he's got a god complex okay what
i'm getting bro
in order to do what this man has done
you you've got to be kind of you got to
be nuts
so i said he's a little crazy and a
little cookie and he's a visionary i
don't know i know i'm not saying i'm
just i'm just saying like
you got to be you got to be off in order
to be able to do what he's been able to
do because you have to have an
imagination and creativity that's
beyond you know beyond the normal person
you know i i i like it i keep calling
himself whatever i like it i'm i'm a big
elon musk fan i think that uh
i like that he doesn't bother you at all
you're cool with it yeah you think he's
toying trolling with people you think
this guy went and he snitched on people
for the right you know for whatever
reasons he did
right or wrong reasons and then he comes
out he's a millionaire again
because he just rattles the cage so much
cool with the snake
no no i'm not cool with the snitching
i'm cool with him rattling the cage i
like that
but from where you're from if you know
one of your people came in
okay yeah so you're cool with them no i
don't i don't know where you're at with
this no i'm just saying i like that he's
a disrupter i like that he doesn't care
i like that takashi let me read
he was a secret service special agent
when he donated to the republican party
and fec filing shows business inside
elon musk has already changed his title
at tesla's
tech techno techno king and now he's
claiming to work for secret service
the tech billionaire donated 990 to the
republican national committee across
january 7th and 8th and listed to
his job as special agent at the u.s
secret service new federal
election commission filing show there's
no evidence that musk has any connection
to the u.s secret service he has
obviously
previously listed aerospace company
spacex as his employer on political
donations
oh my god so my question is you smoking
that january
january 7th and 8th of what year
you're smoking that he's smoking that
marginally this guy is classic
on what he's doing yeah january 7th 8th
of what year
doesn't say just say january 7 if it
says january 7th and 8th that means it's
this year
okay so that means you've donated to the
republican dollars so what's your number
it's a weird night it's a weird dude
but you did it the day after the
insurrection at the capitol
that happened january 6th so that after
that he said i gotta give money to these
[ __ ] over here
like what but 990 what's the the the
night i know that he's got
it there's a code behind a knife of
course he prices things at 420 and 69.
he's a weird out there crazy visionary
that likes banging aliens and that's it
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye